Annetta foreign news russian hackers may
have used a phony news story to create a
growing diplomatic dispute in the Middle
East it involves the country of Qatar a
key military ally of the United States
it hosts a major American air base six
Arab nations including other US allies
have cut off relations with Qatar over
its ties to Iran CBS News has confirmed
the FBI is helping cutters government
investigate a cyber breach of a
state-run news outlet that ran the fake
story our President Trump is praising
the Arab countries move against Qatar
saying he inspired it during last
month's trip to the Middle East he
tweeted this yesterday so good to see
the Saudi Arabia visit with the king in
50 countries already paying off perhaps
this will be the beginning of the end to
the horror of terrorism Jeff / gazes out
cutters embassy in Washington right now
Jeff good morning good morning a top
Russian official this morning deny that
Russian hackers were behind the fake
news story saying that there was zero
evidence but law enforcement sources
concerned that confirmed that Russia is
suspected of at least playing a role in
the cyber attack that created this
diplomatic crisis relationship is
extremely good
president Trump recognized Qatar during
a visit to the region last month Qatar
which hosts the US Central Command is a
crucial strategic partner but earlier
this week six Arab nations including
Saudi Arabia and the United Arab
Emirates broke diplomatic and commercial
ties with the critical US ally citing
its financial support of terrorism
Qataris isolation is reportedly in
reaction to a false news report planted
by cyber hackers on May 23rd the story
attributed false remarks to the Qatari
leader that appeared friendly to Iran
and Israel and questioned whether
president Trump would last an office the
FBI has confirmed the hack may have
resulted in fake news sharing and that
Russia is a suspect part of Russia's
activities to drive a wedge between the
u.s. and our allies writ large CBS News
security contributor Frank saluto says
the u.s. cannot let the incident
undermine its relationship
with guitar which hosts the largest
American military base in the Middle
East US presence in Qatar is so critical
to our campaign against Isis and our
aerial campaign in the region the
secretaries of state and defense have
tried to de-escalate the crisis but
yesterday the president appeared to take
credit for the Arab states decision in a
series of tweets he wrote his recent
visit to the Middle East was already
paying off and that extremism funding
was pointing to Qatar guys let's move
off the social media thing State
Department spokeswoman Heather Ann our
tried to downplay the significance of
the tweets we recognize that Qatar
continues to make efforts to stop the
financing of terror groups during a call
yesterday with the king of Saudi Arabia
the White House says the president Trump
called for unity among Gulf States
Qatari officials they don't blame the
Russians they blame the Saudis for the
cyberattack Charlie thanks Jeff